foreign
[Music]
ER Jen Wilson and welcome to this film
independent present q a for the MTV docs
Paramount plus documentary art and
Crimes by crimes directed by Alyssa
namius special thanks to our lead
sponsor the hifa and our virtual
screenings partner Vision media and now
please welcome our guests today for this
q a director Alyssa namius and film
subjects Jesse crimes and Russell Craig
and I was just wondering if each of you
could sort of talk about how you got
into doing the art that you do and we'll
start with Alyssa okay great yeah I um I
didn't go to film school
um and but I always knew I was an artist
um and I think that's something the
three of us can all relate to Jesse and
Russell and I but um you know you know
from an early age like that it just
there's something about
um about create the creative process and
and that you can't not do it
um and I sort of explored visual art in
college and studied art history and then
I went into architecture
um and while I was studying architecture
I went to Cuba
um on a trip and met an architect there
who had made this extraordinary work in
the 1960s the national art schools
um and he and I embarked on making this
film
um that later I co-directed with Ben
Murray and it actually premiered at the
LA film festival with film independent
about 10 years ago so
um it's exciting to be back here and and
to kind of have continued on this
journey with with exploring documentary
storytelling
you can you can promo your film it's
okay it's unfinished spaces right yes
all right I didn't even say the name
unfinished spaces exactly the word too
in uh in 2012. it did congratulations
um
uh I just want to say I think about that
documentary all the time when I think
about that that abandoned art school all
the time to such a great film thank you
okay uh
um
for Jesse
um do you want to talk about
how you started doing art were you doing
art since you were a little kid
yeah I mean I think it's
um
definitely been something that I've been
doing ever since I was young
um
and you know never really had any kind
of real understanding of what it meant
to be an artist
um I just was always kind of like a
maker always creating things getting
lost in my own worlds
um and then you know it started to kind
of solidify for me when I went to school
and I had some amazing professors around
me who really pushed me and challenged
me
um because they saw something in me that
they thought
had potential for me to actually like
have a successful practice as an artist
and I think that was like the very first
time that I've felt actually seen
um and like valued in a really uh
significant way and so like it started
kind of solidifying for me while I was
in school and then when I went into the
prison system particularly when I was in
solitary confinement that's when I
realized that
you know the the government could
basically take everything from me they
could remove me from my family from the
community strip me of all societal
markings but the one thing they couldn't
take from me was my ability to create
and that is the moment where I knew just
how powerful it was to be an artist
um not just for like self-identity and
self-worth but also
um to serve as a tool of resistance
and so you know I think from that moment
on there was I've never had any other
question in my mind of what I would do
um when I came home or for the rest of
my life
um for you Russell when did you start
doing our
uh started at the age of seven I was a
foster kid you know
me and my sisters was in a foster home
and uh my sister did a drawing of The
Simpsons and I tried to uh mimic her
drawing and didn't get the same
attention but um after that uh I decided
like to always it's like that would
start spark the fire of my our interest
and I've been doing art ever since
long story short
um all right so let's talk about earning
Crimes by crimes um Alyssa how did you
how did you meet uh these two guys and
and start making a film about them
um well I went to Central Casting and
found no just kidding they're they're
amazing but um I actually read this
small uh blog post but really an amazing
blog called prison photography uh by
this guy Pete Brooke
um who writes about art that is buying
about people who are incarcerated
um representation of all kinds and right
after Jesse had come home like he was
still in the halfway house he had hung
apocalypt teen in Philadelphia for the
first time
um and it was there were some
photographs that Pete Brooke got a hold
of and wrote this very kind of
um concise but really powerful uh
summary of what this work was what it's
made of who made it and under the
circumstances and I came across it and I
just I couldn't get it out of my mind
like I I thought that the work was
incredibly
um astute like conceptually
um and also uh in in terms of you know
it's aesthetic
um it challenged like what I thought was
beautiful or not
um it was using the materials of the
prison against itself in a way
um and and like the process of making it
was was exposing
um Injustice and exposing Like Jesse was
saying this kind of human dignity and
the reasons why we even make art in
general so I thought that was really
compelling and I kept talking about it
my husband was like you need to just
reach out to that guy like just just
meet him so uh thank goodness he
encouraged me and I did I Jesse had a
website by then and I emailed him and we
started talking about our we I shared
films with him unfinished spaces and
other work that I had done that is kind
of in this vein of like art let's say on
the margins but not in a negative sense
like art that's operating in different
spaces that kind of outside side of what
we tend to think of as accepted or
sanctioned
um and you know invited him about to
think about the possibility of sharing
his story in a documentary and it wasn't
like hard to convince him but I think it
was a long process of like getting to
know each other and really kind of
developing trust I ended up flying out
to Philadelphia and doing some
preliminary interviews that are in the
film
um still and then we did neither of us
knew it would take as long as it did
because Jesse introduced in part because
Jesse introduced me to Russell and the
other artists in the film and so it was
this oh okay there's a bigger story here
like Jesse opening my eyes to how he and
and his work fits into and is has become
also in service of really
um really like turning not letting us
continue to ignore all of the talent
um and value that is uh that is locked
up in the prison system
so there there's some great animated
sequences in the film uh an example is
the background of your oh yeah right
there
um which I know that Jesse did
um do you want to just talk about like
how
how and when you can see did you always
feel like you wanted
um animated sequences in this or how did
that come about
yeah that was like talking with with
Jesse about okay how could we represent
some of not just a lot of documentaries
will just depict things that you
couldn't shoot right and obviously we
couldn't shoot prison he'd already been
in there and you it's hard to access
um so but what we really wanted to do
um and we worked with this extraordinary
animator Molly Schwartz on it
collaboratively was depict
um the sort of Jessie's inner world and
and when we're showing prison to depict
what we called like impossible views of
the prison like views that were not
stereotypical and images that were like
kind of my architectural background came
into play where we're thinking about
surface and Jesse's work with its
materiality and layering
um and transferring and um looking at
like plans and sections and sort of
um and the imaginative world and not
just prison but also like Jesse as a
child in that these moments of creative
process or of emotional intensity and
Jesse do you want to talk about like you
brought up references that were really
useful and were involved with the
process
early on
yeah and it was like um
you know Alyssa had asked me and Molly
like the question was kind of like
like what is the kind of emotional or
psychological states of being
incarcerated and so the things that the
artist that kind of immediately came
into my mind was
um uh the primary one was William
Kentridge
um particularly because of the way that
he
uses both creation and destruction as a
way to kind of move something forward
um and I found that really interesting
because it also kind of captures the
essence of how time functions within the
prison system where it's like
particularly within solitary confinement
where it's like
time still moves in a linear fashion but
it becomes much less linear and more
cyclical so it's kind of this process of
like creation and destruction that
starts over day after day after day
because your environment doesn't change
nothing ever changes yet your life is
still moving forward and so I think like
conceptually it captures some of the
things of like what it feels like
um to kind of have to manage time as
punishment but also just like the the
idea of kind of creating and then
erasing
um I think is like also something that
kind of relates to like how hard it is
to maintain a sense of like self-worth
and identity while you're in that system
and so for me I think I'm Molly uh did
an amazing job of kind of capturing some
of those emotional and psychological
Landscapes
um that are depicted in the film
um so I wanted to towards the end of the
film you started talking about how
um you created did you create a
foundation or a a project to
help other artists coming out of prison
um you and Russell did right could you
tell us tell us what that's called and
just tell us about it and how it works
uh the writer return
fellowship and we started about four
years ago
and we'll be uh well five
um time flies yeah yeah yeah it's like
what has we've been blessed to keep it
going it's not additional funding and
things like that well um at the moment
um so I've been formerly incarcerated
artists from around the country we uh we
helped them get uh we give them twenty
thousand dollars uh half for their uh um
personal
um you know for their pockets and then
the other half for like a project and
things like that and just help support
and informally incarcerated artists of
um different disciplines
um when we planning to expand it and uh
Jesse can get into like more of the
details on that
yeah I mean we're like
um you know it's been a labor of love
for the past five years uh and
you know we finally received some
significant funding from the melon
Foundation the art for justice fund and
so we're going to be able to basically
expand it into a
um kind of an alternative school for
emerging impacted artists
um and then we'll continue the
fellowship and then we're also building
out a Residency program that will
actually serve artists and Advocates
from across the country and so we're
going to go from supporting like six or
seven artists every year to
approximately 300. so we're scaling
pretty big pretty quick
um but we have an amazing team in place
and we're fully Staffing it out as we
speak and um things are really going in
a great Direction that's amazing
congratulations yeah one thing that also
just might be relevant for this audience
is it's not just visual artists right
it's writers it's filmmakers it's you
know poets like musicians I think so
that's it's interdisciplinary and anyone
who's been right systems impact did or
formerly incarcerated yeah it's every
single creative discipline
um and yeah I mean we we use that term
kind of loosely but you know it is it is
for people who are directly impacted by
the cultural system and Advocates as
well so you said uh ten thousand goes
for making art and ten thousand is is
for their personal expenses right and is
that something you that's something that
you came up with because of your own
experiences coming out of jail and
having a hard time finding employment
right
absolutely
yeah there's there's so many barriers
that you face and particularly for like
artists who you know I mean we consider
ourselves to be serious critical artists
and to be
taken as such in the art world at the
time just was non-existent right
everyone wanted to classify both of us
as like prison artists
um which is fine but also like you know
we we're also artists and so
you know part of the fellowship is like
how do we actually create systems and
structures of Liberation and equity and
and basically figure out how to support
artists to kind of give them that first
that first grant that they need to make
the project that can lead to other
things and like for so many of our
artists this the right of return
Fellowship it's the very first grant
that they've ever received and they've
gone on to get the MacArthur genius
Prize Pulitzer prizes guggenheim's
creative Capital grants art for justice
grants but like we are often the very
first person who funds them and their
ideas and we're also looking to increase
that funding from 20 000 a year to 50.
we're not quite there yet but I think
that very soon we'll be giving out fifty
thousand dollar grants toward us that's
amazing it was cool to see like
obviously when I set out to start the
film this wasn't wasn't like we're gonna
track the origin story of this
incredible initiative and community
building but there was also something
with these two that I think you can see
like in some of the scenes with them too
where it's like they're thinking very
big and completely motivated for you
know powerful reasons and and lived
experience and that was something that
became really compelling to be able to
show you know the Genesis of like of
that
um and and sort of the roots and the the
similarities I think that you two share
and the other artists in the film but
also the differences you know and I
think that's something that was also
really important for us to show and I
think that you guys are doing that
Contin you know that work with right of
Return of
um you know of really working against
and and trying to change racial
disparities and racism in both the
carceral system and the art world as
well
um and and like figure out like how can
we change those the economic gaps too
that that prevent
um folks from being able to participate
in these institutions
yeah and I'd like to jump in here real
quick just he's like he does a lot of
the heavy lifting because like when you
bring an idea in my way I'm like yeah
when it's time to like he's like okay
we're gonna get 50 000 and we're gonna
start at school like it's like he takes
it all away but I just be like yeah I'm
with it I'm with everything but
really taken it to the next level he
does he does all of the heavy lifting
when it comes to mentoring all the
artists and so yeah not all a few like
that I'm saying
all 300 yeah
um
I'm wondering if you know from from your
perspective if you
because it sounds like the boat the both
of you are getting into doing some
um
uh
um social justice work on the with the
on the prison system but I'm wondering
from the two of you from your
perspective what is it
that needs to happen that doesn't happen
when when people get out of jail
um I mean it's the biggest problem work
finding work I mean housing work is is a
few issues uh I would say the biggest
thing would be like um it's slowly
happening but like more people getting
involved as far as like support for like
uh more than just like selective people
like how we was fortunate to make
connections with funders and stuff like
that but there's so many people that um
and then lately we haven't really talked
about this yet but it's like I've been
experiencing like people was expecting
me to provide a lot for them um they you
know they read about what I got going on
and things like that and you know I
understand that I don't have those kind
of resources to help a lot of people so
we need more people that has you know a
lot of money and stuff like that
privilege and things like that to like
expand it and start putting together
systems that can really start helping
people with housing like when I own
first got out it was like hard to get
like holiday I kept getting turned down
so I'm working three jobs and things
like that like you can have the money to
put the down payment on places and
things and they won't accept you because
you formally incarcerated and there's
all kinds of like issues like that and
then jobs as well like we decided to be
artists which was like and that was one
of the things that connected us because
we had that in common that we wanted to
be artists you know no plan B plan a and
we was with and we we just got along we
was born together by Destiny with that
but what about all these other people
that don't have that kind of a drive or
whatever to think outside the box and
make another way when there's really no
way so I would just say like support
systems for um for many you know need
this needs to happen
yeah and I I mean completely agree with
what he's saying
um
I think that
I mean one of the things that I think is
really
I think important to kind of understand
is that
I I just did this conference in LA and
this this woman got up and was like
talking about
um dyslexia
and
uh kind of other forms of like um
um kind of like different ways of that
people learn and kind of access
information
and I forget the exact like statistic
but it's an incredibly High number of
people who are incarcerated who have
dyslexia or some other form of like
mental learning uh ability
and so
it's really interesting though because
like
for me anyway I I look at it and think
like okay
what I mean there's there's a number of
failings that are happening in the
system along the way right from housing
and job insecurity and racism and like
all the structural things that that we
kind of know exist
um uh within the education system
but it's also like how do we create
alternative systems and structures that
are kind of geared towards people who
you know think in a different way and
are kind of creative like they're not
going to be as successful sitting in a
classroom listening to a teacher talk
like maybe they need to be Hands-On and
they're more creative right
and so I I think it's like a very large
percentage of the prison population and
so part of my thinking is like how do we
actually create these other systems and
structures that allow people to learn in
a very very kind of individualized
tailored way
um and then how do we support them in
doing those things because I remember
going through the prison system and like
not one time did anyone ask me what I
was good at or what I was interested in
and it was always like you're bad at
this you did this you did that and it's
like always negative negative negative
nothing was to the positive
and so you know I think entire worlds
kind of start opening up when you ask
people like what are you good at what
are you interested in and then you
figure out how to kind of tailor and
support those things and that you know
that's like a very generalized way but I
do think once you start supporting
people like that then it has this ripple
effect where it's like I can't I can't
put his mask on until I put mine on
right and so like if you think of it
like that every person that you help
then has the capacity to help one or two
other people and it starts kind of
building this ripple effect
um but I think it starts by just you
know at least from our perspective like
trying to help an individual
um
versus like the big system changes where
we're also working and partnering with
Advocates who are trying to pass
policies and our artists try to change
the narrative so that people on the
ground who are voting on those policies
kind of understand what they're talking
about rather than like cold statistics
and numbers
um but it is it's like a very big
um complicated problem
we're seeing some of the change like in
terms of just perceptions when people
see the film right like we've been
screening it now at various festivals
and
um and we had our theatrical run and I
actually have I don't know about have
you guys experienced where you feel like
people come out of the theater asking
different questions than maybe they
might have if they hadn't seen the film
or feel or even I know like Gilberto
said that he feels like people maybe see
him differently like more are more open
or more positive about
interactions afterwards
um but hopefully we can kind of be a
part of that by continuing to to share
this and you're you know your courage
and sharing your stories has also I
think opened up we've had people in
audiences who share with me or with you
that they have been impacted by
incarceration directly but haven't felt
comfortable talking about it right
yeah the I think that is like an
important part it's like this film is
just as much about narrative change as
like the artists that we partner with
the works that we make it's it's all
kind of getting people to see something
from a much more human lens uh rather
than the sensationalized stories that
people were used to kind of digesting
about who we put in prisons
um and so yeah I've I've seen the I've
seen that I've had those experiences
after
um the screenings where people have come
up to me and talked to me I mean
numerous occasions
um and I think that is part of my
Collective healing right like a lot of
people feel such shame and stigma that
they don't even talk about it and so I
think like getting it to a place where
we can actually have conversations and
normalize talking about traumatic
experiences can actually help grow
something positive
so I want to finish with two questions
um where can we see the two of you where
where is there anywhere we can see your
work
um that you're doing currently
um is it social media or or are either
both of you having exhibits right now
for me uh one of the main places would
be Instagram
or like or because people be thinking
art or dot Craig dot T1 is when I post
things that's going on we have a few
things together and we have some things
coming up so definitely
um you know check out Instagram is where
I mostly post uh with squant um come
forth in the near future
yeah same for me Instagram is like a
great place to kind of like see what I'm
up to and knew where I post upcoming
exhibitions um I will say we both have
our in a show in Miami during Basel
um
what is that
December yeah early December right yeah
time is a flat circle at this point but
it's getting back to solitary time kind
of time
um but yes so we have a show coming up
in Miami uh at the end of this year and
um we will have a couple other shows
coming up early next year uh we just
I can't say anything at the moment and
you have um right of returnusa.com right
is the is the org website yeah um and
then we have crimesfilm.com for the for
the film that has links to all of their
websites that was my next question is
where can um other people who didn't get
to see this See Art and Crimes by crimes
totally yeah so um definitely follow
these guys on Instagram because they'll
they'll tell you you know where it's
playing and then also we have at crimes
film with a k
um and we have crimesfilm.com
um and the film's gonna be uh it's
playing in various museums and cultural
centers and theaters right now um for
the next couple of months and probably
Beyond and then also it's gonna be on
Paramount plus streaming before long so
stay tuned and we'll we'll be announcing
lots more opportunities to see this is
going to blow up you're just gonna blow
up
also a modeling Gallery where website
because like for example of a joint show
in Aspen right now me and Jesse
that also with our website Milan
well thank you so much to the three of
you for coming to talk to me today it
was great to find out about this film I
enjoyed it so much I think other people
are going to love it too and find a lot
of of meaning in it thank you for having
such a pleasure
thank you
[Music]